garud connelly wrote a memoir about his
experience and you have stayed
relatively true to his story but you've
also fictionalized it so you have to
make a choice in terms of the essence of
Garrett's book and what it is you want
to preserve and what you want to
dramatize so when you're thinking about
that and talking with Garrett about how
you're gonna adapt this book what were
the most important things that you
wanted to preserve even if you're
preserving them theme Attica Lee by
adding fictional elements there was a
few things one was like what do you
leave out what do you keep in the other
aspect is you know what's the most
important aspect of the movie and for me
that very clearly throughout every part
of the process became the family element
even though the entry point for me as a
kind of a morbid curiosity coming into
the book was I was fascinated by getting
some understanding conversion therapy
because I'd heard a glimpse of about
what it was I was expecting more blood
on the page what I got out of it was
this complicated understanding that the
reason it exists it existed and still
exists is because the motivation for
sending people there young people and
you know influencing older people to go
there and the reason why the
infrastructure exists is because it
actually is born out of love and the
need or interest to care for people my
feeling coming into the book was I this
is a hateful group of people that have
created a hateful thing to do hateful
stuff it wasn't that it was more
complicated so I was trying to stay true
to that essence and along the way it
meant moreso fictionalizing some of the
conversion therapy characters but not
the practices and choosing what to
distill from that and the biggest
question is how do you reduce a person's
life or at least a massive chapter of
their life into two hours without
feeling like you're not doing it the
proper service how do you how do you
distill that in the best possible way so
there was a lot of decisions to make
about living living things out and what
I would ask you about the actor next
year Troy when you come onto the project
Gary is a character that is rooted in
the story but is also a creation of your
screenplay what were the important
conversations that you had about what
that's what this character needed to
represent in terms of the audience in
terms of agency for the audience to
connect to the story yeah I mean I think
so like you said in in the sort of early
drafts of the script Gary was a very
different character and a much smaller
one and I mean I guess I'll let Joel
answer
why did why did you feel like we needed
I'll start and then I want you to
continue because oh I you know creating
a bunch of different characters within
therapy was really important to me and
and Gary to me was somebody who it
really was an evolution and in a
collaboration with Troy and I and I
would like him to talk about some of
those aspects but the idea of having
someone there that wasn't just a devotee
that wasn't coerced and and a believer
but somebody who was like the hope for
the hope for what Garrett eventually
became somebody who maybe had the agency
but but not the family to support and
the feeling like once I get across that
bridge I'm making a [ __ ] - but he's
smarter than everybody else and somebody
that makes that turn and what was
interesting to me was allowing all of
those actors in that group Troy included
having their own narrative and being
included in what that was so I didn't
just like impose my will on people
because what they could contribute
themselves was going to be as valid and
as important so you know we talked about
that stuff a lot yeah yeah go ahead I
know I saw an opportunity to you know
when I first read the scenes you know
where Joe goes to the doctor and the
doctor sort of provides this like this
first sense of I just remember feeling
so relieved when I read the scripts
because I was like finally is someone
someone here seems to have their like
head screwed on
and and so then to kind of be given the
opportunity to kind of further that and
provide an alternative for Jared that
that was a real exciting moment for me
and and felt like something that I I
definitely wanted to be a part of Joel
I'm going to ask you about dr. Julie in
real life that Jerry Jones plays did you
have any conversations with her and how
important was she two guards on story I
went on a like a fact-finding mission to
Arkansas with David my assistant who
plays Michael my assistant in the movie
who's also a co-producer and a long time
poor guy was a longtime assistant to me
and a beautiful friend and and it's also
part of one half of creating a podcast
with Jared the author called Anna raised
about a broader history of conversion
therapy so he and I Lucas hedges
beautiful Lucas and Garrett went to
Arkansas and we met the folks we did as
much we looked at all the places where
love and action had operated out of but
we sat down with dr. Julie and
everything that in that conversation
that came not only from Jared's running
of her in the book but what she said to
me about her dilemma at the time being a
member of that church and having in her
head what she knew became the dialogue
of that scene Jenny what it's about
like the dialogue in this film musically
because the stroll was telling his own
approach to it you could make this film
any number of ways you can make it much
more dogmatic you can make it
melodramatic you can make it much more
judgmental and all those ideas kind of
lend themselves to a certain way of
writing music when you're thinking
thematically about the point of view
that the music is going to have what
were the conversations you had with Joel
and what did you settle on in terms of
overall themes about how the music was
not going to be the movie that Joel
didn't want to make in terms of being
too on that on the nose yeah exactly the
I think the most important thing he said
before was not to mock LA and everybody
that works and and goes there an area
not to not to make it out to be this
terrible place because I kind of went in
there thinking that same thing like how
could
we'll do that but it was really
important for us a lot of our first
conversations were about how can you
make a introspective multi-layered music
of intelligent and thoughtful and
heartfelt but have it not sway the
audience too much into you know we
wanted everybody to make their own
opinion about the place and what Jared
was going through and so how could we do
that musically and and then we the whole
process of making the film I think what
I found really interesting in the first
few interviews of being asked along with
my partner Saunders here was you know
there are so many different emotional
states and and society based things that
are happening in this film and musically
we were like okay so now we're at the
camp and now we're at home with them and
now he's in college and just had this
ordeal happen and now and it was all
these different types of music that we
needed to kind of cover which was which
is when we first started doing our
interior like I remember getting asked
the first questions like so what was the
process like in doing the music I was
like I can't even remember all of the
music because it's so there's so many
different styles and yeah you start
talking about one style of music and
then I was like but then there's this
other kind of music that's in there too
to show this and that and then this and
then that I can't even wrap my head
around all of it I drag them in earlier
than expected because I kind of had a
feeling that there was gonna be I didn't
really know I couldn't listen these guys
know I'm totally not Musical at all so I
was like can you guys come in earlier
than expected it and start giving me ten
music cuz the last time we'd
collaborated together I fed them temp
music that's on the gift and yeah and I
was that guy who was like hey could you
write something just like this and they
like you know says like can you be
involved early on is that okay rather
than they just hand you a cart right we
prefer it it's the great way to go
Nicole when you read Gerdes book the way
he describes his mother is incredibly
complicated and depending on what you're
bringing to the book you're gonna react
different way
I'm wondering when you read his book and
then maybe this is not the right order
and then actually meet Martha was that
the sequence and did the book set you up
for the person that you thought you're
gonna meet or did it turn out to be
something very different in terms of
your expectations a mixture I mean when
you're creating someone that actually
exists there's a way in which you go in
and I go in through my emotional
responses to to the story into and to
really my child because I've got to come
through it as a mother and feel the
things that I relate to her on and then
find the way in which I'm going to
portray her and I don't really want to
when it's a real person I don't really
want to meet them too early because then
I get into pleasing and wanting them to
pat me on the back and say well done and
that's not a good place as an actor it's
more about finding my truth so that I
can come through that and then morph
into her and and really find her essence
and she was so I sort of kept her at a
distance and I and I tried to through
the book but also through Joel find out
what he felt and that's how I rely
heavily on the director and then she
visited the set kind of halfway through
when I had already established how I
wanted to be as her and she kind of and
I was nervous and she and I thought oh
gosh but she she was so loving and she
brought her sister as well and so the
two of them were able to kind of and
instead then once they started
encouraging me and deeply affectionate
towards me I was like okay now I want
you here all the time but such an actor
I want to thank you all for skipping the
Dodgers and coming to this film